we have breaking news of a disaster in
Genoa Italy where at least 10 people
have been killed in a bridge collapse
according to police sources the massive
span along a major highway gave way this
morning dropping vehicles into an
industrial area at least one survivor
has reportedly been rescued in Genoa on
Italy's northwest coast Charlie d'Agata
is following the story from London
charlie good morning well good morning
authorities say the collapse happened
during a sudden and violent storm that
swept through the northern city at 200
yards section of the Morandi bridge came
down over an industrial area as you said
there are fears it may have damaged gas
lines below in a video posted on Twitter
a man is heard crying oh god oh god as
the bridge span comes tumbling down a
green truck had just managed to stop a
few feet ahead of what had become a
cliff now Italian mergency services have
identified at least 10 vehicles in the
collapse that's leading to expectations
of that high death toll but ongoing
reports describe people still being
pulled alive from the rubble
Italy's Transport Minister described
what's happened as an immense tragedy
the extent of which is still unknown
Vienna of course we will continue to
follow developments in this story
charlie thank you